So the answer is no, that even with any
of these restrictions, we still don't have a good
definition. So, let's consider all the restrictions. So, the
first one was, if everyone is friends with Alice. So
that would only work if they don't have any
other friends. Let's say this is Alice. We've got
Bob and Charlie. They're both friends with Alice. But
Bob is also friends with Charlie and Charlie is friends
with Bob. That means that to figure out the popularity of
Bob we need to know the popularity of Charlie. To figure
out the popularity of Charlie we need to know the popularity
of Alice as well as the popularity of Bob. So we're never
going to get to a solution. We are going to keep
bouncing back and forth between Bob and Charlie doing this. The
second choice only if no one is friends with Alice. Well,
if no one was friends with Alice, that would remove these links.
It doesn't solve our problem. We're still not going to be able
to give a popularity score for Bob and Charlie. The third choice
only if there is a friendship path from everyone in the graph
that eventually reaches Alice. So adding this link would provide that property,
but it still doesn't solve our problem. It doesn't give us a
way to figure out the popularity of Charlie, because to know that,
we need to know the popularity of Bob, which we need to
know the popularity of Charlie for. We still end up in this cycle.
The final choice seems, possibly more promising. It says
there are no cycles in the graph, so if
we want to remove this cycle. We could do
this. In this case, we'd be okay, right? We could
figure out the popularity of Bob, by figuring out
the popularity of Charlie, which depends on the popularity
of Alice. Where we're not okay, is if Bob
has another friend. Let's say Bob is friends with Diana.
Well then, to figure out the popularity of Diana,
we need to know the popularity of Bob. Where
it breaks down is, suppose we also have Diana
and Edgar, and Diana's friends with Edgar. To figure out
the popularity score of Diana, we need to know the popularity score
of Edgar. We don't have a cycle, but we don't have an answer
either. To figure out the popularity of Edgar,. We are going to go through
Edgar's friends, and the way the Python code is written. This could actually
work, right? Because if we define popularity when you have no friends.
Well, if the friends of p is empty, when we go through this
loop, the score is going to be 0. So, if you answered there are
no cycles. That's at least worth credit for this, that could be correct.
In terms of the mathematical definition, it doesn't make very good
sense. We still needed a way to know the popularity of
Edgar. We've sort of defined things in this case to say,
if you have no friends, your popularity score is zero. And
the Python code will work for that. But it's not a
good way to define popularity. So its very arbitrary to say
we're going to make Alice the one whose popularity score is predefined
as one. There is nothing Alice could do to make herself
more popular. That's not very fair to
Alice and it doesn't give us meaningful scores.